i am what they call empathic and i
didn't understand this at the time i
feel people's
energy so especially when i start to
connect with a soul they'll make me feel
the bond that they shared with someone
but then they'll make me feel how they
died so if they die tragically i'll
taste blood sometimes it's all like if
someone had an aneurysm or they had a
bleed out um
if they couldn't communicate if they had
a tube down their throat i'll feel like
someone's restricting my throat and it's
just for like a split second but i've
learned to understand what that was so
imagine feeling all of those things and
not knowing what it was
and i was afraid of everything i
couldn't leave my house at this point i
also went through and you know my senior
year i lost my high school sweetheart to
a drunk driver so i dealt with death at
a very young age and
he was he was kind of my plan like i was
kind of like okay
he was an artist a musician
he was going places and i was just gonna
go with them and i was just gonna figure
it out as i go and then all of a sudden
january of my senior year i lose him and
it was like i lost everything i lost my
direction i lost my future i lost like
you know your first love like all of
that
and i experienced pain and all these
other emotions
so
literally graduated high school kind of
i don't want to say the chip on my
shoulder but with sadness and in
kalakakua bay the dolphins come and they
love to swim with dolls with humans
right and so we used to go swimming with
them the local community would tell me
oh yeah you know dolphins can
hear everything you think they get you
know their psychic and so on and then at
one point i was after like a few months
of swimming with them almost every day i
was thinking wow you know i was i got i
befriended this
young
dolphin and we used to go
you know swim twirling and jumping and
all this uh we went to this camp and
somehow or another i had developed this
really really bad
what i came to see later on migraine
headache
and i didn't even i was so shy i didn't
even tell
the teachers that i was so sick
and um and i remember we were in these
huts and we all were put to bed and of
course the moment you lay down with the
microphone
it's even worse than ever right and i i
felt so ill
and but still too afraid to tell anybody
and so i just walked out of the hut i
can't even believe i did this but it was
night and i walked out of the heart
and down the little steps and it this
camp was by the ocean and i stood on
this
feeling good feeling good reaching for
more reaching for more and just
listening to the mantras and chanting
the mantras when out of nowhere i felt
this presence of a baby in the back seat
it felt like a baby in a car seat behind
me
and i started crying cause it felt so
real to me i felt i felt so real that i
started being deeply moved by that
experience
and then i heard this inner voice say to
me this voice of your intuition
inspiration
loud and clear your baby's coming in
march
and it was so loud and authoritative i
know it's just like in my face i was
like okay march march here comes the
baby in march the baby's coming in march
and so i started you know really getting
heady about like oh the baby's coming
march and i started getting back on the
timeline and so the second i saw that
happen i just said okay universe you
take this that doesn't work show me a
sign that this baby's coming in march
and i want the sign to be lily's i just
chose that sign
yeah i mean i can definitely
i can conjure it
i mean i don't do it a lot but ever
since i was very little i can
i don't know what what the term would be
i do have a capacity to
hear messages or
connect with people who aren't in the
body or
i have to be careful though so i think
it's it's being an empath so 30 of
people highly sensitive
and then of that 30 20 to 30 um four
percent of them are empaths
and some of them are medium type empaths
some of them are animal and past plant
empaths you know and they're linked to
the intelligences so you asked about my
capacity and it's really
i think it's a gift you know it's scary
sometimes to be picking up so much
information no matter what and that's
one of the stresses cortisol for the
reintegration into this new normal is
the idea of like wow okay i have to
i have to pace myself and
you know i just pick up on so much
information that i you know i just have
to prepare myself for hiding in
bathrooms again sometimes my personality
changes a little bit like when i'm in in
new orleans
first time i was there
i was fine i was standing on a street
corner you can see this beam of light
coming like right through me and i felt
like it was protection and i was fine
went back another time i was actually
pushed during a live show by a soul
and one of my cat the stuff was flying
off of their cameras the lights the
batteries oh yeah like right in front of
thousands of people i you can't even
make this up it was like energy it was
energy it was energy
something going on in those theaters
down there i mean and he tripped and i'm
like you were pushed i watched it and
he's like i didn't push i tripped i'm
like there was nothing for you to trip
on like he was like so fighting that
that spirit was doing this and i'm like
no i'm telling you they're just they're
just messing with us it's really
interesting because bear plays a really
big role in spirituality before he was
gone bear was really deep he he was like
there's something more than just what
the bible tells you you know you talk
about feeling and he just knew this but
he did open up my eyes to that world and
then when i lost him
that's when i really started to see
signs and i started to go to spiritual
healers and i was talking to
angel readers and i started to really
dive into this world and i'll tell you
the first time i went a woman reached
out to me and said
this person keeps showing me a bear and
he wants me to speak to you yeah and
this woman like i was like i'm so sorry
but i don't believe this stuff so i
would go down with her and then twirl
back up and all this but but she would
never ever bump against me or touch me
or anything and if i tried to touch her
she would move her body exactly the same
distance
and i didn't know and so i was thinking
as i was swimming with her at one point
why
why don't they
touch us and then i thought maybe i
didn't give her permission to touch me
so i thought in my head i gave you
permission to touch me and
she just rubbed all over me like in that
instant and so the the reason i was
telling you this story is that when you
realize
oh maybe i'm in the new network of the
universe and and i'm actually
interacting with it and actually these
inner thoughts and this inner dialogue
i'm having is actually a dialogue with
the whole can i tell you a memory that
maybe only you two would know
would you come speak to me and i'm not
kidding you she told me about this time
i'll never forget it the diamondbacks
won
the world series um
so i i had i was in high school yeah it
was our senior year and bear and i like
hopped this fence was a this house
downtown there was no one was living
there and we watched the fireworks show
from the backyard we didn't tell anyone
it's like as a kid you don't go tell and
people that
she told me
and i was like
okay
okay i'm gonna listen now like i had
goosebumps i immediately just started
blowing my eyes out and i'll tell you
this woman i can't find her i wish i
could her name was trisha
she opened my eyes at 18 years old to
spirituality but to this whole world
and
i started making vision boards i started
to manifest i started to do all these
things
and people at my age like they thought
it was crazy but this woman really
opened up my eyes to really like bear
leaves you feathers everywhere still to
this day i'll think about him and i'm
not kidding a feather will fall out of
the sky
on to my children or on to me or they're
in i was at a bookstore pulled a book
out and i'm flipping through a book
there was a feather in a book a week
later i get a letter in the mail from a
reader and in the letter was a little
prayer card and on the back of the
prayer card was a picture of archangel
gabriel who was typically depicted
holding lilies
so on the back of the card that he sent
me he said i don't know why but i felt
that you needed this then
early march rolls around and i wasn't
pregnant
and so i was devastated because here i
was i was like the universe doesn't have
my back what's going on and i walked
into my husband's office i was
hysterically crying i'm like when is
this going to happen i really thought it
was coming i thought it was now what's
happening
and we just sat there and he held me and
all of a sudden the phone that was
sitting on the desk
my phone
started playing a song
all of a sudden out of nowhere
you know when you think like all my
phone's doing something weird too like
go to turn it off but it i looked at the
phone and as i went to try to turn it
off i heard the lyrics of the song and
the lyrics were way go lily way go lily
wiggle lily then i look closer and the
album title
the song is called way go lily repeating
the word lily over and over again and
the album title is i see the sign
can't make it up can't i get up these
guys are laughing
and i said
in my 12 12 or 10 year old way if there
is a god
please take away this headache right now
and
not only did the headache
dissolve
instantly
but the most incredible joy and ecstasy
and love
swept all through me
and i had tears pouring down my face and
there
and
from that moment on i always knew what
i'm this is what i felt as you asked me
this question so i always feel like when
i talk about my gift it's always guided
by spirit maybe there's someone on this
call maybe it's for someone listening
right now that will find healing in this
what i saw was a young male step forward
and he showed me my symbol for where he
wanted to take responsibility for his
departure
i did taste something and i saw a
medicine bottle that's my symbol for
where they took something or mixed
medications without knowing that caused
or attributed to their departure i find
that a lot of times souls that leave the
physical world tragically unexpected
they tend to step forward more so
okay
because we then beat ourselves up with
maybe a survivor's guilt my first thing
to people is
just pay attention just be open to what
goes on around anything that reminds you
of your loved one i don't care what it
is
and you think of them at that moment
know that that's them with you at this
moment and you're not alone
i think that's the biggest thing don't
say oh
mom i know it's you if i see four red
cardinals by sunday you
you can't do that it's like then once
you start to get that then like take
baby steps if you have a hard time
meditating just take it to a minute a
day just concentrating on your breathing
for one minute then try three minutes
that's what i did my mind is always full
of chatter and i i worked up and i don't
put so much pressure on it some people
can meditate for hours i can only do 10
minutes at a time that's what works for
me
i think we put pressure and we think
things connecting with our loved ones
has to be this or it should be this or
it should feel like this
it's a simple thing of sometimes i smell
cigarette smoke i know it's my my dad's
mom i know it's her
uh sometimes i smell my my grandfather's
cologne i know he's with me i smell
gardenias i know my grandmother is with
me for a split second